Jordan peels follow-up to his masterly
debut get out is a terrifying plunge
into the double depths of humanity and
hidden in the movies opening scenes and
throughout the film or a stack of clues
that cleverly reveal its dramatic twist
ending
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jan and
today I'm really excited to peel back
and break down for you the many layers
of the horrifying and thrilling film us
we've got tons of Easter eggs you may
have missed and hidden secrets to
examine and there will of course be
spoilers so take care if you haven't
seen it yet let's quickly review what
happened at the end of us so we
understand exactly how all the clues in
the movie foreshadow and explained the
final twist the tethered were originally
created as part of an experiment to
control their above-ground counterparts
when that failed the doubles were
abandoned in their underground world of
tunnels but red Adelaide's double helps
the tethered rise up against the
above-ground people killing many of them
and forming a human chain across the
land
however the twist we discover is that
the tethers leader red is actually the
original a delayed in the 1980's
fairground scene young Adelaide
encountered her double in a Hall of
Mirrors Adelaide's double overpowered
her and took Adelaide's place with her
parents above-ground in the final
showdown present-day Adelaide kills red
burying the truth about who she really
is underground forever or at least
that's what she thinks because her son
Jason was also in the basement when red
revealed that Adelaide was originally
one of the tethered and it seems like he
may have overheard her secret which is
why he gives her a sort of strange look
and pulls down its mask as they drive
off in the final scene so now we've got
the ending covered let's jump back to
the movies opening scenes where Jordan
Peele laid clues for everything in the
ending and the twist the movie starts
with young Adelaide watching a Hands
Across America commercial which is full
of imagery and themes we'll see repeated
during the film the idea of doubles and
twins has immediately brought up with
the mention of 6 million people and 12
million eyes the Twin Towers the
repeated letter Gees of the Golden Gate
Bridge and the words from sea to shining
sea accompanying an image of a
lighthouse which appears twice once on
the left of the screen and then
immediately flipped with a mirror image
to the right and to cap it all after the
promo ends we see a copy of young
Adelaide reflected in the TV screen
sitting next to a white rabbit toy now
that's intriguing because the advert is
a huge clue to the real identity of the
ted's leader when young Adelaide is
switched with her tethered counterpart
her tethered double steals her Michael
Jackson Thriller t-shirt and leaves her
with only her hands across America
t-shirt over the years she spent growing
up underground Adelaide who we now call
red found inspiration in memories from
her previous life above ground her
memory of the 1986 Hands Across America
charity event during which millions of
Americans formed a human chain across
parts of the country to raise money for
the homeless is something that's been
seared into her brain and so red takes
inspiration from that to organize an act
of rebellion where the tethered send a
bloody message by rising up killing
their above-ground counterparts and
recreating that human chain from Hands
Across America the clothes worn by the
tethered give their group the feeling of
a cult or escaped prisoners which in a
way they are and read who designed these
outfits took inspiration from several
classic horror and cultural icons from
the time prior to 1986 when she was
still above ground the red work were
jumpsuits and the single gloves worn by
the doppelgangers were a nod to Michael
Jackson's Thriller video as well as his
custom of donning a glove on just one
hand their outfits also evoke Michael
Myers overalls in the Halloween movies
and likewise their globes are a shout
out to Freddy Krueger's look in the
Nightmare on Elm Street series a VHS
tape of which you can see by the TV set
at the start of peels film which is
doubly fitting as it's one of the
directors favorite Horrors another of
those VHS tapes by the TV is the mid-80s
horror film turd which hints nicely at
how us will end because as well as
featuring monsters living beneath the
streets who eventually emerge
above-ground tchard also includes a
government cover-up and interestingly
for peels movie people who go missing by
the way the idea of conspiracies also
pops up early on in us when Zora says
the government uses fluoride in water to
control people's minds not only is this
a pointer to the failed experiment
revealed at the end of this movie but it
may also be a little shoutout to the
movie dr. Strangelove
especially given Jordan peels love of
Stanley Kubrick films like The Shining
another key detail to understand the
film's ending is the constant repetition
of the number 11 in the very first scene
there's a news and weather promo all on
7 at 11:00 the surprise young Adelaide
chooses at the fairground I want number
11 she tells her dad there's the alarm
clock that hits 11 minutes past 11:00
shortly before the Wilson's doubles turn
up and wreak havoc and those same
numbers are on the roof of the ambulance
as it drives away at the end of the film
and importantly a man with a jeremiah
11:11 sign pops up by the beach in the
past and the present the man with the
sign is a harbinger of doom as you can
tell from his biblical verse therefore
this is what the Lord says I will bring
on them a disaster they cannot escape
although they cry out to me I will not
listen to them this biblical warning
precedes Adelaide's traumatic
experiences in both the past and the
present what's intriguing for this movie
though is that this particular chapter
of the Bible is all about how God's
people have forgotten their own history
where they come from and the commitment
and promises they made to get where they
are all of which ties in nicely with the
way Adelaide tries to bury the memory of
what happened in 1986 if she wants to
forget how she ended up where she is
today in other words she's desperately
trying to avoid confronting the fact
that she's a doppelganger who used
violence to replace the original
Adelaide and now she's terrified what
consequences her actions back then might
have for herself and her family today if
she returns to the scene of her original
crime the films frequently repeated
Bible quote is a stark message that goes
out to its protagonists and viewers in
general and also given the double
meaning of the film's title specifically
to the u.s. when Gabe asks his families
doppelgangers what are you people the
question word wat implies a certain
dehumanization as Gabe doesn't quite see
the doubles as human beings Reds answer
we're Americans is unnerving for the
Wilsons who see the strange but familiar
beings in front of them as different not
equal to themselves as a visual double
of the number 1 the number 11 perfectly
suits the film's imagery and themes of
doubling mirror
repetition but through the ages the
number eleven has also acquired some
interesting symbolism as it can signify
transition excess peril and conflict all
of which there's plenty of in this film
and it can also symbolize sin and
repentance which seems very fitting
given that this movie suggests that we
need to take a long hard look at
ourselves to find the source of our
individual and collective problems
rather than constantly be rushing to
blame other people or groups for our
self-inflicted disasters that is we are
our own worst enemies the owl that pops
out and frightens young Adelaide at the
fair fits in with the murals of trees
and wildlife around her but given the
setting is a Vision Quest with a sign to
find yourself the bird symbolism is also
interesting for the film in some
symbolism owls are connected to magical
forces and the idea of being able to see
beyond your immediate reality some think
the film seems to implore us to do and
it's also intriguing that symbolically
owls embody the duality seen throughout
the film as they can be considered a
good or a bad omen
depending on what happens next clearly
for young Adelaide it was a bad omen
though things worked out better for a
doppelganger who got to experience life
above ground inside the Hall of Mirrors
young Adelaide starts whistling the tune
- the nursery rhyme itsy bitsy spider
but then her clone takes over whistling
it - the nursery rhyme is about a spider
climbing up a drainpipe before being
fleshed down again when it rains and
then when the Sun comes out and dries
away the rain the spider is able to
finally emerge from below the lyrics
match exactly how young Adelaide's clone
comes up to the surface then drags
Adelaide back down below before
returning to the surface to take young
Adelaide's place in the world
above-ground years later red finally has
her moment and comes up to the surface
for the untethering
and that final emergence from below by
red is foreshadowed in the scene at the
holiday home where present-day Adelaide
spots a tiny little spider creeping out
from below a bigger toy spider on the
coffee table the cages of rabbits
gradually revealed during the film's
opening credits for another fascinating
detail that point to the film's final
twist Pele moves quickly from an image
of young Adelaide's horrified face at
seeing her dove
for the first time and cut straight to a
close-up of a caged rabbits face
indicating young Adelaide's ultimate
fate of being caged underground with the
tethered who like rabbits have been
living in tunnels and were used for
experiments the flashback to young
Adelaide and her parents that the
doctors after her traumatic Hall of
Mirrors experience is another vital clue
to the film's body swap twist two
details are particularly crucial first
Adelaide has been acting differently to
her usual self and she doesn't speak and
secondly there's her mother's words I
just want my little girl back a few
scenes later we learned that the Wilson
family's doubles do not speak which
explains why young Adelaide couldn't
speak after the phone firm and the fact
that only present-day Adelaide's
doppelganger can speak but sounds like
someone who hasn't used her vocal cords
in an extremely long time his further
evidence of the Hall of Mirrors body
swap young Adelaide's mum didn't realise
but she never did get her little girl
back as the child living with her that
day in Santa Cruz was actually her
daughter's clone this hint is echoed in
the present day when either late tries
to tell her husband Gabe why she feels
so uncomfortable on holiday I don't feel
like myself she says but just like young
Adelaide's parents Gabe doesn't know or
understand what that really means and
replies I think he looked like yourself
then there's the way later during the
home invasion that read orders Adelaide
tether yourself to the table and act
which mirrors how young Adelaide's
doppelganger chained her to the bed in
the underground tunnels before leaving
her there and replacing her above-ground
of course there are other signs that
things are not all they appear to be for
example in the background here there's
the board game guess who and notice that
other game magic is actually turned
upside down
much like Adelaide's life has been since
the hall of Marez encounter with her
double heals film begins by showing us
how we like to think of ourselves the
Good Samaritans of the Hands Across
America promo and ends by exposing our
shadowy side which we so often prefer to
keep hidden both from ourselves and the
rest of the world essentially IRS's a
film about society's hypocrisy the
everyday violence of our privileges and
power as well as issues such as class
race xenophobia and general fear of the
other as well as the way so many choose
to ignore the ties that bind us and look
instead to sow seeds of division keeping
others down in order to raise themselves
up in a constant game of whack-a-mole a
game we see young Adelaide's dad playing
as she wanders off soon to be lost to
her parents forever now did you catch
any other details in us and do you have
any theories about the ending let me
know in the comments below
coming up I'll have new videos on pet
symmetry and chilling Adventures of
Sabrina so if you enjoy deep dives into
your favorite Horrors be sure to
subscribe and hit the bell to get all my
new videos tapleft for my theory on how
us and get out are connected or tap
write for another video you're sure to
like thanks for watching and see you
next time you became movie lovers